I always tap his locker just like it was
in high school it hits me every time him
and Wade laced up next to each other
their lockers were side-by-side for
years Schuyler mentioned that everything
to him feels different it's it just
feels different
Wade was the only child he just always
had a big heart even as a child he never
wanted you mad at him you know he was
just a bundle of joy
I just noticed how much everyone
gravitated to him because he was just so
friendly to everybody he made everybody
feel like they were special once we were
able to give him the same a routine
that's when I first started to hang
around and I just knew that was somebody
that I wanted to be like and somebody I
wanted to be around as much as possible
all right Scott Mays here with small
forward slash power forward slash Center
Gatorade Player of the Year
Wade Sims how you doing guys all right
you know I like to get kind of personal
in my interviews so I want to ask you
how's Leslie doing Leslie slaughter your
girlfriend oh that's my girl that's my
girl
we doing pretty good you guys had like a
good chemistry you guys joked around a
lot with each other you guys balance
each other out a little bit describe
your relationship with him yeah I'd like
to say it's kind of a yin and yang I'm
more of a you know steady guy and he's
just the flamboyant person who does a
lot of theatrics that everybody you know
loves and he keeps everybody easygoing
so I think that was really beneficial
for me and helped me be myself but also
open up Wade took Skyler's brothers and
sisters as his siblings and they
accepted Wade like as their brother we
got to a point where I coached him and
then I had to turn him over to somebody
else and just to see him grow we were
all happy and excited I think he always
knew that he was I think he was just
trying to play me
uh-huh I secretly prayed that he would
stay here and go to LSU I remember one
day he just kind of entertained maybe
goin somewhere off and I was like oh god
no please
it was exciting for me in a dad and a
former player it's always honored to see
your kid go in your footsteps did weeds
commitment here affect yours absolutely
absolutely I love playing with weight we
knew each other team in and out and we
played with each other for 10 12 20
years so I wanted to keep him how did
the bond between you guys evolve once
you got to college once you got to LSU
definitely you're stronger I think the
more we were around each other are just
relationships your school I'll be there
cool in coach rube you know that's
pretty bad he is the one it would kind
of ease everything I think here's a glue
got in the way he played because he
played to make other guys better he
played the win and you know anybody
likes to play with something like that
so it was so effortless for him to help
this team win games
members of the LSU basketball team are
grieving tonight cell phone video shows
the moments before Wade Simms was shot I
got the phone call in the middle of the
night and I just remember us racing to
the hospital and and then it I don't
know I really don't remember like a
whole lot I actually don't remember all
of the month of October or November
obviously and I mean that Davis for the
most part of blur I was just praying to
God that he would be all right you know
dad I know he was shot you know just I
would hope that you know he would
survive we got there whatever but you
know unfortunately I wasn't
we begin with the tragedy hitting the
Baton Rouge sports world LSU basketball
star Wade Simms shot and killed
overnight I just passed him and just
kind of sat back like I was in shock and
disbelief I just couldn't stop crying I
didn't know what to do I called my
parents because I my parents are
obviously close with Wade like his or
with Michael with me and just cry I feel
like
everyone a new way all the time just a
local person smile was contagious for me
it kind of feels like he's just on a
really long vacation and you forgot his
phone here it's just it's just really
hard for me it's hard for all of us my
heart breaks for Skylar I mean it just
it it just breaks for Skylar he checks
on me and I'll check on him and just try
to you know keep in touch but you know I
feel like I'm dying in the inside but
you know I just my heart just aches for
him as well
it's your worst nightmare so I always
say that the worst thing that could have
ever happened to me has happened I'm
Wade was my entire life
how do you feel his presence
as a team yes I'm and sometimes when
some shots going in the game I don't
feel that I could ever feel the boy I
just don't foresee that happening I know
that I'll be empty
I say for the rest of my life
my heart has a hole and I tell him it
bleeds every day
I don't ever see that being repaired I
know about a grace of God he could
change you know situations but I just
right now I can't see that what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content